here there is no room for mistakes
and a mistake any slightest mistake
can cost you your life
it is not a game
if
it is not to be able to world
to underwater market it is a lifestyle
there is a lot of controversy
and continue doing the most selective fishing in
the
world fishing
efe  - It hurts
many people that what they think we
entered with a put water and it would
kill kill but things are not like that many
vacations sections to observe to
dedicate ourselves to enjoying not what is the
marine environment to enjoy not the
species to try trying to learn
each  time every day a little more of
the blue planet
you have to be well considered in
the species
neither take it too small and too
big
take
what you know you can deal with its
sale your consultation
d
is very
consistent
bernstein
being intelligent is not power the world
how we have done it
be smart keep it
watch it and somehow make the
best of it